was sagst du dazu dass du nur zwei
millionen mal gegoogelt wirst allesklar
de hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video seht es schon ich sitze wieder
hier vor meiner als auch immer dass ich
alles aufgebaut ist ich bin zu hause bei
mir wieder an meine ferien sind vorbei
ich studiere jetzt wieder und deswegen
habe ich mir gedacht wir spielen einfach
mal das hanauer game wo wir jetzt gerade
babys hier nur wie das funktioniert bei
dem hanauer game geht nämlich darum dass
wir zwei sachen vorgeschlagen bekommen
und wir müssen sagen okay wird sache b
mehr gebummelt als sache und wir wissen
nur von sache aber oft geprügelt wird
ich glaube ihr kennt es also ich habe es
ja schon öfters mal hochgeladen wir
haben jetzt beispielsweise cheneys new
jerseys butt war und ich glaube butt war
ist ja dieses bier oder oder was ist
dass ich glaube einfach mal dass es
öfter gegoogelt wird da liege ich jetzt
komplett daneben
ihr merkt schon ich kann das wirklich
sehr gut
lina böses omen hardware definitiv
weniger gegoogelt nämlich 90.000 mal der
klima eine million mal table tennis
definitiv mehr als 90.000 mal nämlich
201 1000 samsung hatten wir glaube ich
sogar schon mal und ich meine samsung
geht richtig häufig google also locker
acht stelle ich mal oder so samsung
nämlich 11 millionen das ist elf
millionen 8 ständig koblenz sex ist ja
eine bank aus england glaube ich bin mir
nicht so ganz sicher hat ist meine ich
laura als samsung nämlich 550.000 bnp
paribas haben das ja aber auch mit den
ganzen unternehmen denke ich dass denke
ich eigentlich kann ich überhaupt denken
ich würde sagen gleich viel aber ich sag
jetzt einfach mal rein
doch 555 hintereinander richtig ägypten
definitiv mehr als bnp paribas nicht
story versus lionel messi lionel messi
definitiv zwei millionen mal
lionel messi wird nur zwei millionen mal
gegoogelt ok lionel messi
du wirst nur 22 millionen mal gegoogelt
monatlich ich weiß ok 2,2 millionen
ultra viel und ich werde auch nicht 22
millionen mal gegoogelt aber beinah war
es glaube ich zehn millionen mal oder so
ich weiß ich habe einfach mehr im
öffentlichen interesse steht aber ich
würde einfach mal interessieren was
lionel messi darauf antworten würde also
herr messi was sagst du dazu dass du nur
zwei millionen mal gegoogelt wie ist
alles klar dicker ich dachte echt wäre
es ein korrekter typ immer zurück zum
thema nein nicht zurück zum thema messi
was sagst du dazu liste so viel weniger
ins neymar gegoogelt wirst wenn man
tiere breiten passant neymar ist ein
mitspieler aus deiner mannschaft der den
wie ich finde wirklich sehr gut fußball
spielt und zu recht mehrfach gegoogelt
wird als de facto raid 1 verbund an
trainern ok messi ich würde sagen an der
stelle ist inter viren auch beendet muss
man dem kontinent bedanke mich auf jeden
fall bei ihnen dafür dass sie sich die
zeit genommen haben hier in dem video
quasi mir nochmal kurzes interview zu
geben warum sie denn nur so wenig
gegoogelt werden
und mit dieser arroganten aussage würde
ich sagen machen wir jetzt mal weiter
mit dem hanauer game ages bc ist wieder
eine bank und das ist ja mittlerweile
schon die dritte bank deswegen würde ich
sagen lauer als zwei liga messi die
scheiß bank wird oft was bist du für ein
mensch ist momentan ja okay du kannst
jetzt wahrscheinlich wirklich nicht so
viel für aber ich also wenn das
basketball wird 27 millionen mal
monatlich gegoogelt und es kam nur ist
das stadion in dem messi spielt und ich
würde sagen dass kampwirth weniger oft
geprügelt und nämlich 301 1000 m s sie
wenigstens wird dürfte google das
stadion in dem das spiel
brasilien wir definitiv öfter als rolle
als 1000 mal gegoogelt nämlich mehr als
das doppelte moscow mule ist ein sehr
leckeres getränk wird dem die weniger
gegoogelt als basieren nämlich 370.000
nicht mitgerechnet gay auf jeden fall
mehr auf sie geht in die millionen
nämlich zwei millionen marlboro in
englisch für eine reihe stellen alles
klar weniger als zwei millionen würde
ich sagen nämlich nur 60.000 mal das
nächste was wir haben floyd mayweather
sehr viel öfter in die mallorca eine
million hätte ich sogar gedacht noch
mehr xbox waren auch mehr als eine
million nämlich vier millionen jobs ja
ich weiss nicht genau wer ist die
leitfrage wieder finde ich an lauer als
vier millionen mal würde ich mal einfach
sagen nämlich 246.000 mal mist period
definitiv auf dem ich habe acht gescort
leute das mega gut auf jeden fall
weniger als bmx nämlich 3600 cheneys
take away mehr als der sabbat
ich würde sagen mehr weil das ja
irgendwie jeder google wenn er irgendwie
essen bestellen will cello weniger oder
auch okay cello mehr da habe ich jetzt
natürlich verpackt das ist natürlich
ganz typischer luca an dieser stelle mal
wieder aber wir haben antoine griezmann
in den nutzern wechselt 1000 mini cooper
safe mehr ich war selber mini und 12
millionen okay ich habe sogar gedacht
noch mehr feminismus auch mehr als 1
konnten nämlich weniger rasiere ich
heute eigentlich auch noch mal
irgendwann letzte runde freunde jetzt
strenge ich nicht mal richtig an den
kragen denn hier fand listerien wenig
als long island ice die das hatten wir
vor wünschen dass 41.000 bilder würde
ich sagen
heyer als mit period nämlich 90.000
damit dark knight rises auf jeden fall
mehr nämlich 370.000 lektion results bin
ich mir nicht sicher würde ich sagen
gleich viel ich da aber einfach höher
nämlich 1,2 millionen ok autismus gibt
keine ahnung weniger als 12 millionen
ich bin mir eigentlich sicher mit
800.000 okay das ist denke ich mehr als
nein doch gleich viel ok gleichviel
800.000 fensterhebel wahrscheinlich
prinz daniel lo als cruise würde ich
sagen nämlich 370.000 damit haben wir
schon sieben erreicht mount everest auf
jeden fall öfter an ja wirklich öffnet
habe schon acht erreicht rolex auch
öfter als 78.000 dem eineinhalb
millionen mal kam us- die mega oft
nämlich vier millionen mal robert
redford auf jeden fall weniger als kann
juristen nämlich 450.000 prada mehr als
54.000 nämlich 800.000 die haben schon
zwölf score leo tolstoi weniger ich
preis nicht mal wer das ist mir
persönlich heute gefunden
hey produktion kommt vielleicht man
messi auf myvideo hier rausschmeißen
herr lincoln es so ernst
wahrscheinlich soll jetzt das video auch
irgendwie noch mit messi betiteln
kapitalismus auf jeden fall häufiger
nehmen es 301 1000 dann haben wir an
allen spots ist wer auch immer das kiss
ich bin mir nicht sicher ich würde sagen
okay war ich hier schon mal so gut
das war es hier vor dem video meine
damen und herren ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen wenn es das getan als mit ihrem
buch beschreibt mal in die kommentare
gute
wenn jetzt noch dran seid morgen und
übermorgen kommen noch videos wo ich
noch bei meiner familie zu hause bin
aber danach kommen wieder hauptsächlich
solche videos wo ich hier von meinem
schreibtisch sitze und zocke deswegen
schreibt mir jetzt alle mal unten die
kommentare was ihr wiedersehen wollen
also scheint so was wie akinator oder
clever bord oder godzilla irgendwas oder
irgendwelche neuen spiele die so in die
richtung geht ich lieber diesen
browsergames wie halogen oder knabbern
oder so empfindlich mégane als schreibt
und in kommentare wenn ihr euch freut
dass das tier jetzt wieder sind alles
mehr kommen jetzt bewegt wie viel spaß
die letzten wort hatte messi ok-team
portal youtube präsentieren